what up space fam goals in here from
anime out pro and i'm back at it again
to discuss the latest crazy developments
in the one piece story we definitely got
some huge moments in this one so make
sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
reviews on this channel and want to keep
them coming the best thing to do is
smash that like button until it's as
blue as frankie's hair
and share this video with your cultured
nakama if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos it looks like there will be
another
break next week and while we impatiently
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist where i got videos about the
yonko
warlords supernovas all the different
and interesting types of devil fruits
and more
link in the description now without
further ado let's jump into this one
spoilers and all
this chapter is called i've kept you
waiting and in a way
you can say this title applies to weekly
shonen jump issues right now and their
understandable breaks
but we'll see who's keeping whom waiting
in the actual chapter
as we know though when it comes to one
piece it's always
worth the wait last chapter the minx and
their soolong transformations
were hyped up understandably because
it's a hella hype transformation
and here we get kaido responding to that
by saying that he's aware that they're
about to transform into ravenous
beast warriors but he's the furthest
thing from worried he's back to his
usual cocky kaido
and simply laughs excitedly about the
idea facing off against an army of minx
now that kaido is in tough guy fighting
mode
it will be interesting to see who can do
anything to him and how
all-star jack is in the house and he
congratulates our samurai for coming as
far as they did but he claims that it
was possible because of the inadequacy
of the beast pirates
now that they're ready though he
proclaims that they'll never again lay a
finger on kaido if this is true or not
remains to be seen but jack is right
that it will be harder now that the
element of surprise has been used
and everyone is supposedly on guard and
ready was the sneak attack
all for nothing then no as i mentioned
previously it set an important tempo for
the war and illustrated that kaido is
not invincible and can be hurt
and can even be made to scream like a
wee lass the morale boost
that follows cannot be overstated but
still it's only a beginning and the hard
part is only getting started
of course jack here is super significant
because of the rematch we've been
waiting for him to have with inuwarashi
and nekomamushi but not only that
jack caused them and their people pained
because of rhizo
and this is gonna be rizo's chance to
set things right as best as he can
as well nekomamushi simply states he's
been waiting for jack
so jack is the waited for man everything
flows well from one character to the
next here as inuarashi picks up the
discussion
adding that jack is the man who
destroyed their country that stood for
over a
thousand years because he was looking
for that man
and rhizo picks up from there saying
that he is in fact
that man he is spartacus aka rizo
and finally he gets a chance to pay back
those who did so much for him and not
only that
he intends to pay the debt twofold
that's a goosebump inducing moment
and i personally really hope we see
soolong inuarashi
sulong nekomamushi and rizzo just triple
team jack
for now though we start seeing some
non-inuwarashi and nekomamushi's
long transformations take place they
want their masters to go after kaido
but if non-red scabbards can take out an
all-star even in tsulong
form is questionable at best and i need
that satisfying personalized victory
over
jack too this may sound obvious but the
soolong transformations make the minks
look like
absolute beasts and i love it the panel
with the musketeers looks especially lit
and i can't help but wonder how many
more puns i'll make in this video the
transformed minks
look at kaido in the distance and the
hype is real
not that they'll be able to take down
dragon title or anything
but still the setup is so sweet
beastified beasts trying to
take down the king of beasts a dragon
and we
see a number 7 of the giant numbers in
this chapter who actually
doesn't look like an ant next to kaido's
dragon form which is no small feat
and who dwarfs jack in size again not an
easy thing to do
we have beast after beast in these
panels this is like the most
op zoo of all time interestingly enough
jack needs to resort to calming his men
saying don't falter the zulong
transformations don't last
long it's significant that he needs to
utter those words
suggesting that beast pirates may have
faltered and freaked out otherwise
and may still do so we jump inside where
queen calls out jack
and king in turn calls out queens saying
he's definitely not the sensible one
either
obviously king seems like the most
rational and stoic of all the all-stars
and the strongest as well as the name
suggests while they make
villain small talk shinobu tries to free
momo but of course
fails king takes her and bam throws her
at high speeds
right into a building like you might
swat away a beat
luffy ever the straightforward one says
what we're all thinking that that seemed
bad and wonders if shinobu's okay
as if chernobyl was the perfect
distraction though momo starts getting
freed
the chains break and momo starts
floating funnily enough
he comments on how scared he is because
he's so high up
pretty funny after verbally holding his
own in the face of the strongest living
creature
while awaiting an execution but he's
still just a kid and we shouldn't forget
that
shinobu turns out to be okay while king
goes to kick
momo and then gloriously sanji blocks
his kick
and we see that it was in fact him in
his raid suit
i'm glad that sanji's dream of being
able to turn invisible has come true
and of course he wasn't just chasing
women sanji is ready to help his friends
when the chips are down
as we all knew he would be sanji saves
momo
from the deadly king by passing him to
shinobu
who's well enough to run with him as
this exchange takes place
sanji also tells momo that him declaring
his name was amazing showing that he was
here for that moment
and this is such a beautiful moment too
i've been missing sanji and for him to
come and save momo from king and queen
while also saying while we were
hopefully all thinking to momo about his
speech
that is epic in his large bird dinosaur
form
king seems to all but skewer sanji with
his beak as he slams him at a high speed
right into a building to luffy's shock
in hours
obviously in that dangerous situation
sanji definitely
could have been impaled but it probably
won't happen i hope he's not down for
the count but the fact remains that he's
not going to be able to take down
king even if he can get up from this
still despite what happens from here
props to sanji who got one over on both
king and queen luffy then leaves yamato
to help take care of momo with shinobu
hilariously a dynamic appears that i
didn't really think about
since yamato considers herself to be
odin momo is by dislogic her son
and so she answered that naturally it
should be okay for her to take care of
her son
in the midst of all the other crazy
things happening on this battlefield
kaido's own daughter helping his rival's
son who she views as her own son is
pretty hilarious and i definitely don't
think we've seen the last
of that comedic plot point then as if
kaido
sulong minx king in action and sanji
returning wasn't enough hype
we get big mom rushing towards luffy on
prometheus with her sword in hand
she is not playing around my dudes she
wants to handle this quick
so then she can eat of course no small
motivation for big mom
and it's funny getting big mom's
perspective when she tells luffy that
he's the man that ruins the fun for
other people
by constantly crashing parties i love
how she makes her murderous self seem
like a victim
and positions luffy as this selfish
party pooper
big mom's attack is deadly and
completely disintegrates everything in
its wake
good thing luffy dodged rather than
trying to block it this woman is as
strong as they come
as some people are shocked at this
display and at the idea of fighting two
title level opponents
luffy wonders how he'll get to the
outside when opponents like big mom keep
getting in his way
and as big mom is wondering what
happened to luffy
nami comes in with the much needed
distraction she of all things
steals zeus back to big mom's shock how
insane this
is i hopefully don't need to point out
not only did nami steal zeus before
that almost get killed by big mom for it
she has the gall to take the yonko's
homie again
it's not just luffy his whole crew is
willing to completely disrespect yonko
and that's amazing it really is nami has
a great little conversation with zeus
she's mad at him and says that he has to
either
choose nami or big mom obviously zeus is
big mom's homie
and he says he can't defy her even if he
prefers nami
big mom straight up says she'll
extinguish his soul if he disobeys her
so with tears in his eyes he apologizes
to nami
even as he's telling her to die nami
with tears in her own eyes
says she hates him and like a girl
breaking up with her boyfriend
says that their relationship is over now
i do think this is more so a distraction
than anything else and i would be very
upset if their relationship was in fact
over since these two are perfectly
matched and the last thing we need is
for nami to lose her power upgrade
so i'm hoping we get to keep seeing
these two shine brighter than prometheus
together after this battle
and you know how i was just talking
about how nami had the gall to steal
zeus for the second time from a yonko
well that's not even the biggest
shocking thing that happens to big mom
this chapter
frankie comes in singing frankie freedom
rider
and slams his cycle right at the big
mom's face
as brooke cuts zeus in a more classy
less in your face
way ah frankie the communa of one piece
can we please get a blue like up in here
to
honor his glory the bystanders are
shocked that people would really do this
to big mom and frankie just makes it
worse as if it wasn't even worth
noticing he mentions whoops
did i drive over something and then says
whatever it's not like it was a flower
or anything
he smiles in the coolest way possible as
nami calls out big bro
what a boss frankie is and what a boss
crew the straw hats have become
we're at the stage where not only luffy
but the other members are more than
prepared to disrespect yonko to their
face
sanji nami and frankie were the mvps in
this one
and they were absolutely glorious wow
and that
my friends my nakama is another great
chapter for the books
as always let me know what you expect to
see in the next chapter
and what your thoughts are about this
one i just keep
loving frankie and nami in particular
more and more
it almost scares me how much i love them
it really does but anyways if you did
enjoy this video and want to keep the
reviews coming
you know what to do channel the glory of
frankie and his blue hair
and turn that like button blue and share
this video with your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos it looks like there will be
another break next week
and while we impatiently wait for the
next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the yonko
warlords supernovas all of the different
and super interesting types of devil
fruits you can imagine
and so much more link in the description
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you